in a recent episode of obsessed we saw
Brian Berg build an eight-foot-tall
spaceship out of cards with nothing
holding it together except good design
and he made it look easy but how easy is
it Berg is gonna give us a quick lesson
on the basics like how to use your hands
as tools and what shape to start with
once you master those simple skills you
can use them to build pretty much
anything and I'm here to show you how to
turn ordinary playing cards into
something amazing
first step here's a list of don'ts
you're not gonna want to try to do this
on shag carpet you're not gonna want to
try to do it maybe on glass something
that has a little more texture to it
just a normal tabletop also don't try it
outside don't try it in front of a fan
don't do it in a moving vehicle those
things are all problematic to build your
foundation berg advises against the
traditional triangle shape instead he
starts with squares and right angles I'm
gonna hold the first card in my left
hand he's gonna Park it here so it's
really hard but you got to remember not
until you've got all four of these cards
put together are you gonna let go
there's the fourth card I'm still
wiggling but look I'm just gonna lean
all four of those together this is a
little sloppy each one of them is
leaning in notice each one is at the
halfway point and notice that I've
created a little box in the center
that's this is the fundamental beginning
cell of any card house from small to
massive if you can accomplish this
little box and get that to happen
you're really like 90% of the way there
but I'm just gonna keep making these
little boxes and as I go this will kind
of turn into what I call the grid he has
a couple extra little tips to get you
from the first story to the second to
the third fourth fifth however tall you
want to go I'm just gonna quickly throw
a little roof on this
you're really just trying to get the
most even roofing that you can that
isn't you know five cards thick in one
place and one card thick in another in
the very center so imagine it getting
thicker and thicker and thicker in the
middle but not so much on the edges
you're gonna create this dome effect on
your roof and what that's gonna cause is
your cards to dance around they're not
gonna want to sit but you'll notice I
did put the numbers up the numbers are
up because typically playing cards are
sort of shaped like this and that means
that every card kind of creates two
contact points and that that cards just
gonna want to sit there all right if it
were like this that card is gonna want
to dance around when you put all these
steps together you have endless options
of what you can build and you'll be
surprised at how strong your card houses
are and to prove it Berg is gonna build
another grid and then stress test it
okay so we're gonna build the same grid
we built before I'm gonna use two or
three cards at a time to just kind of
beef up the strength of this thing a
little bit and you could do it with one
card you know depending on what you want
to do with this thing I double them up
triple them up a lot to just make it
more of a brick house less of a card
house so that when the clumsiest person
in a room is moving around which is me
and I get too close to it that you know
just the slightest draft doesn't cause
it to start to fall apart these larger
structures becomes really strong
so you might have something sitting
around that you can use to stress test
your house of cards so in this case I
just happen to have a concrete block
sitting here and I'm just gonna set it
out there do we have another one
don't have another one